THANKS TO THE VISION,
COMMITMENT, AND POLICIES OF
DONALD TRUMP.
AND THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW REACTION IN
FLORIDA IS DAN BONGINO AND NRA
TV CONTRIBUTOR.
WOULD WE HEAR IN STUDIO, JOHN
BLASER, DIRECTOR OF FOREIGN
POLICY STUDIES AT THE CATO
INSTITUTE AND LISA HARRIS,
FOX NEWS NATIONAL SECURITY
ANALYST.
GREAT TO SEE ALL OF YOU.
JOHN, I WANT TO GO TO YOU ON
THIS.
IT'S AMAZING TO GO BACK AND
LISTEN TO THOSE WHO SEVERAL
WEEKS AGO WERE SAYING THAT TRUMP
WAS ON THE VERGE OF BRINGING US
A THERMONUCLEAR WAR BECAUSE HE
CALLED KIM JONG UN ROCKET MAN
AND HE SEEMED TO BE ALL OVER THE
PLACE.
THEY DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT'S THE
WAY TRUMP MOVES AND OPERATES.
HE IS NOT BEING GIVEN CREDIT.
HE SAYS LOOK, ANYTHING CAN
HAPPEN HERE BUT THE NAYSAYERS
AND THE NEGATIVITY, I DON'T
THINK ARE COMPLYING WITH THE
REALITY THAT MOST AMERICANS ARE
SEEING HERE.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT
THAT TRUMP'S APPROACH TO
NORTH KOREA IS NOT THE ONLY
PEBBLE ON THE BEACH.
I MEAN, NORTH KOREA HAS VERY
RECENTLY ACHIEVED WHAT IT HAS
ALWAYS WANTED TO ACHIEVE WITH
REGARDS TO ITS NUCLEAR AND
BALLISTIC MISSILE PROGRAM, AND
THAT HAS REALLY STRENGTHENED ITS
BARGAINING POSITION AND GOES A
LONG WAY TO EXPAND WHY THEY
CHANGE THEIR POSTURE.
IT'S ALSO THE CASE --
>> Laura: YOU ARE SAYING THAT
NORTH KOREA WOULD HAVE DONE THIS
ANYWAY WITH THE HILLARY CLINTON?
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE ARGUING
QUESTION WORKS BECAUSE THERE ARE
OTHER FACTORS.
SOUTH KOREAN PRESIDENT MOON
JAE-IN.
HE'S HAD ALMOST THE OPPOSITE OF
TERMS APPROACH.
IT'S NOT BEEN GOING BACK TO
MAXIMUM PRESSURE.
IT'S BEEN CONCILIATION, SOMETIME
POLICY AND NEGOTIATIONS
ET CETERA.
HE HAS ORCHESTRATED MOST OF THE
SORT OF DIPLOMATIC OVERTURE.
A LOT OF CREDIT IS OWED TO HIM.
A LINE OF CREDIT IS OWED TO THE
FACT THEY NOW HAVE LEVERAGE WITH
THE NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
THEY FEEL MORE ON AN EQUAL
BASIS.
THEY CAN SIT AT THE NEGOTIATING
TABLE WITH THE UNITED STATES.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE THESE THINGS
IN.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THINGS.
>> Laura: LITERALLY, THIS IS
WHAT I THINK TRUMP IS IF HE DOES
AND IF HE DOESN'T.
IF NORTH KOREA WAS MOVING APACE
WITH MORE TESTS, MORE BALLISTIC
MISSILE TESTING, THEY ALSO HAD A
FACILITY COLLAPSE ON ITSELF.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY IT WAS BUILT,
WHAT IT WAS TUNNELING
UNDERNEATH.
COLLAPSE ON ITSELF.
THE WHOLE NARRATIVE IN
NORTH KOREA IS COLLAPSING BUT
THE PRESSURE THAT WAS BROUGHT TO
BEAR ON HIM WITH THIS
UNCONVENTIONAL AMERICAN LEADER
WHO DIDN'T FEEL LIKE HE HAD TO
PLAY BY THE OLD RULEBOOK, I
THINK MOVES IT TO THE PLACE THAT
IT IS NOW THAT NOBODY PREDICTED.
NO ONE IS PREDICTING THAT
DONALD TRUMP WOULD BE THE ONE TO
OVERSEE THIS SUMMIT AND TO CARRY
OUT THE SUMMIT.
AGAIN, SEEING WHERE IT GOES.
I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT THAT WE
HAVE TO BE CAUTIOUS BUT COME ON.
THE FACT THAT HE'S NOT GETTING
ANY CREDIT FROM THESE PEOPLE, I
THINK IT'S DISHONEST AT THIS
POINT.